essayiez-vous de provoquer quelqu'un à faire
quelque chose de particulier
oui dites-nous ce que vous pensez utiliser votre tête
[Musique]
donc
je rappais pendant que j'écrivais de la poésie
d'accord
et donc j'étais dans le rap je
suppose que vous pourriez dire du collège
quand je  j'ai écrit mon premier poème
et après avoir entendu à la radio qu'il
y avait d'autres poètes
qui faisaient des disques et c'était ils
vendaient et ça marchait
alors j'ai décidé de changer la euh
la méthode de ma porsche
[Musique]
ils ne '  Peu importe si nous arrêtons la violence
ou non, ils ne se soucient pas de la violence des gangs
[Musique]
alors
vous